شكرا طاهر مشاهدينا اهلا بكم الى هذه
الساعه الاخباريه والتي نخصص معظمها
لتغطيه التطورات في السودان والبدايه باهم
الاحداث حتى الان
خلينا نقول بالوعي او بادراك الطرفين
لخطور الوضع
يؤكدوا للعربيه انفتاح طرفي نزاع سودان
على التفاوض والسعوديه الموقع الاكثر
ترجيحا لاستضافه المحادثات
الخارجيه الامريكيه
من السودان وتشكر السعوديه لمساعدتها في
عمليه الاجلاء
ورغم الهدنه اشتباكات عنيفه في احياء
متفرقه في الخرطوم وسط تحليق للطيران
الحربي
ايضا من اخبارنا الليل
الولايات المتحده قول ان مئه الف روسيه
قتلوا او جرحوا في بخموت خلال اربعه اشهر
[موسيقى]
الهدوء النسبيه الذي عاشته مدن الخرطوم في
الهدنه السابقه اصبح الان امرا بعيدا
المنال بعد ان تواصلت الاشتباكات العنيفه
في مناطق مختلفه من الخرطوم اليوم تم رصد
الطيران الحربي وهو يقصف مواقع في العاصمه
وفي مدن اخرى من الولايه ايضا افادت مصادر
بتحركات لقوات الدعم السريع رغم الهدنه
يقول المبعوث الامامي للسودان فولكر في
لقاء خاص مع العربيه ان طرفي نزاع لم
يلتزم ابدا بالهدنه بشكل كامل لكن على
سبيل الامل يقول بختيس انه تم التوافق على
اجراء محادثات فنيه بين الجيش والدعم
السريع من اجل تثبيت الهدنه وحتى موعد
اجراء هذه المحادثات ربما ستظل هذه
المشاهد يا سائده في الخرطوبه
[تصفيق]
هذا سماع صوت صاروخ على
[موسيقى]
اصوات للمدفعيه
ثقيله
حتى البعيد واشتباكاته واضحه
[موسيقى]
الدعم السريع
وقوات الشعب المسلحه
مع الان بوضوح من منطقه
وفي حديثه الخاص للعربيه قال المبعوثه
الامامي للسودان فولكر ويخس ان العمل جاري
لوضع تفاصيل اللوجستيه لمفاوضات السودان
مع الامريكيين والسعوديين
ورجع رجح بختس ان تجري مفاوضات الحلف
السودان مشيرا الى انه الاولويه
مؤكدا ان طرفي الصراع ادرك خطوره الوضع
ووافق على محادثات فنيه للوصول الى
التهدئه
اداره
الاعمال الفنيه هلا مع الامريكان
والسعوديين فبطئت بالارجح
سيتم بالمحارب الارجح طبعا يعني الجانبين
لازم ان يوافقوا على
هذا المكان
وقال بختار للعربيه ان طرفي النزاع في
السودان باتاي يدركان للانتصار العسكري لن
يكون الا بثمن باهظ على السودان
في الاسبوع الاخير تكريما تغيير
باللهجه ويمكن تغيير تغيير خلينا بنقول
بالوعي او بادراك الطرفين لخطور الورد
لانه وين بتعرف يعني بالاسبوع الاول
الاسبوع الثاني
فالجهتين كانوا
يعني كانوا يعبروا عن تاكيد انهم سينتسرون
على الجانب الثاني
فكانوا يطلبون باستسلام الجانب الثاني الى
اخره انا في ادراك اكثر حاليا انه
الانتساب العسكري غير ممكن
الا للسعر
عالي جدا
وعلى النقيض من هذه الاعمال اكد رئيس
الكيني وليام روتو ان طرفي الصرافه
السودان رفض الاستجابه لدعوه جاد والاتحاد
الافريقي والمجتمع الدولي لوقف اطلاق
النار واضاف خلال اجتماع مع مسؤولين
افارقه وامميين ان الازمه الانسانيه في
السودان وصلت الى مستويات كارثيه وسط نقص
في المياه والغذاء والادويه مشيرا الى ان
عدد النازحين مستمرون في الارتفاع مع فرار
المزيد الى دول الجوار
نائب المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه قال
بان بلاده نجحت بجلاء اكثر من الف مواطن
امريكي من السودان عبر ثلاث قوافل
ليس هناك اي عدد محدد نفصح عنه لاعداد
المواطنين الامريكيين الذين غادروا
السودان المواطنون الامريكيون هم من
يتخذون القرار بشان المغادره بحسب
اولوياتهم تواصلنا خلال هذه الازمه مع
اكثر من 5000 مواطن امريكي مقيم في
السودان واجلينا الفا مواطن منهم عبر ثلاث
قوافل
كما ثمرت الخارجيه الامريكيه جهود
السعوديه في استقبال المواطنين الامريكيين
وايضا للمساعده في عمليات الاجلاء من
السودان
اود القول ان السعوديه لعبت دورا مهما ليس
فقط في استقبال مواطنينا لكن في دعم
الرباعيه وكانت حلقه وصل في الدفع بتمديد
هدنه الاثنتين وسبعين ساعه
هذا وعبرت القياده المركزيه الامريكيه عن
شكرها للقوات المسلحه السعوديه
لمساهمتها ودعمها لجهود اجلاء مئات
المواطنين الامريكيين من السودان الى جده
وقال قائد القياده المركزيه الامريكيه
مايكل كوريلا انه عبر خلاء وانه عبر خلال
اتصال هاتفي برئيس الاركان السعودي فياضى
رويلي عن تقديره وشكره لسماح السعوديه
بفتح قواعدها ومجالها البحري والجوي
لتامين وصول مئات المواطنين الامريكيين
بامان الى جده
ومنها تم اجلائهم
هذا ووصلت سفينه جلاله الملك ابها الى
مدينه جده وهي تحمل 41 مواطنا سعوديا ومئه
واحد وسبعين من رعايا دول اخرى كما صرحت
الخارجيه السعوديه ان عدد الرعايه التي
اجلتهم من السودان حتى الان يفوق خمسه
الاف شخص من بينهم
225 مواطنا سعوديا والبقيه من
100 وجنسيتين مختلفه
والله هذا يعني شعور لا يوصف ان الواحد
يكون كله يعني هو والاسره كلهم بامان
الناس كثيره هناك عندها مشاكل ما قادره ما
عندها فلوس ما عندها مصاري ناس كتير معلقه
نحمد الله سبحانه
لاهل المملكه هل هذا الاست
[موسيقى]
ثمار اندلع حريق في منزل احد سودانيين في
منطقه الفردوس شرقي مدينه الخرطوم دون ان
يعرف اذا كان بسبب او هذا الامتلاع بسبب
اشتباكات بين قوات الجيش والدعم السريع او
لسبب عرضي اخر
[موسيقى]
والحصل الليله في الفردوس هما مؤقت حاجه
لكن بس مرقنا مع نادي النار مشتعله في
البيت ما معروف مصدره والحمد لله شعب
السوداني شعبي يعني متقاتل نحمد الله
ونشكر يعني النهارده طلعت سبحان الله ما
معروف من
[موسيقى]
صور في الامم المتحده توقعاتي بفرار ما
يفوق عن 800 الف شخص من السودان اثر
النزاع في البلاد كما اضاف المسؤول ان
ثلاثه وسبعين الف شخص فرو متجهين الى دول
الجوار وفي سياق ذات عبر منسق الامم
المتحده للشؤون الانسانيه عن مخاوفه من
امتداد ازمه السودان الى دول الجوار واعلن
المنسق ان الوضع الانساني في البلاد يتجه
الى نحو كارثي وان شحنه من الادويه عالقه
الان على الحدود ولم تدخل السودان بعد
كارثه شامله يتجه اليها الوضع الانساني في
السودان
منسق الامم المتحده للشؤون الانسانيه في
السودان وصف الوضع بالكارثه متخوفا من
امتداد الازمه لدول الجوار
[موسيقى]
تصريحات داعمه لما سبق ادلى بها مسؤول
اللاجئين في الامم المتحده متوقعا فرار
اكثر من 800 الف شخص من السودان
بالاضافه الى 73 الف شخص لاذو بالفرار الى
دول الجوار
هروب جماعي من المعارك والوضع الصحي
المزري مع استمرار خروج المشافي عن الخدمه
ومقص التجهيزات
بينما تواجه شحنه ادويه من الصحه العالميه
عوائق للدخول الى البلاد
اعزانا المشاهدين نترككم مع هذه الصور
التي وردت الى العربيه قبل قليل من قوات
الدعم السريعه والتي تتحدث فيها عن
السيطره او استمرار السيطره على مبنى
الاذاعه والتلفزيون في ام درمان في الوقت
الذي كان اعلن فيه الجيش السوداني استعاده
السيطره بشكل كامل على هذا المقر
عبد الله
الان احنا مسيطرين وموجودين وبعدين الرجال
[موسيقى]
احنا
كما اشرنا قوات الدعم السريع في هذا
التسجيل الذي وصلنا قبل قليل تقول بانها
ما زالت تسيطر على مبنى الاذاعه
والتلفزيون في الوقت الذي كان اعلن فيه
الجيش السوداني السيطره على المقر بشكل
كامل وهذا في اطار طبعا تضارب البيانات
والاعلانات اعلانات السيطره ما بين
الطرفين احاول ان نتابع صوره مباشره من
اندرمان مع الصحفي في مكتب العربيه شهدي
نادره اهلا بك شهدي هل هناك اي تاكيدات
بشانه الجهه التي تسيطر على مبنى الاذاعه
والتلفزيون حتى الان
مرحبا قبل ان نجلسوا للجهه التي
تسيطر على المقر الاذاعه والتلفزيون اشير
الى تجدد
الاشتباكات نسمع ذوي اسلحه ثقيله في هذه
الاسنان من اتجاه ام انت غربي ام درمان لم
يتسنى لنا بعد معرفه المكان تحديدا ولكن
دوي اسلحه ثقيل يبدو مسموع
حاليا هنا في منطقه منطقه كرري التي اخطون
بها هي يبدو ان
اليوم الذي شهد الاشتباكات منذ منتصف نهار
هذا اليوم ان الاشتباكات ربما تتواصل حتى
في اوقات
المساء اليوم كما تعلمت الاشتباكات طلعات
جويه وكثافه نفذها سلاح الجو السوداني في
عده مناطق بها العاصمه السودانيه الخرطومه
مدنها على ثلاث من ضمنها كانت مقر الايداع
المقرر الاذاعه والتلفزيون اضافه الى
مدينه الخرطوم بحري عده مواقع من بينها
سلاح هذا المظلات التي وبه الوحده الطبيه
لقوات الدعم السريع التي قالت في بيان انه
اليوم تعرض الى مدفعيه الى استهداف
احدى المعسكرات في ضاحيه كافوري منطقه شرق
النير ايضا شهدت
اشتباكاتها ام مناوشات وكذلك طلعات جويه
مدينه الخرطوم لو كنت تسمع الان هذه
الاصوات
اذا كما يشير زميل شهدي نادر بان
الاشتباكات ما زالت مستمره
وتصاعدت بشكل كبير كما نستمع في هذه
اللحظات من ام درمان عبر الهاتف من زميلنا
شاهدي نادر في استمرار للخروقات التي طالت
الهدنه المعلنه بين الطرفين
طيب شاهدي هناك نقطه مهمه جدا بالاضافه
الى مبنى الاذاعه والتلفزيون هل هناك
مناطق استراتيجيه يجري
او تجربه محاولات السيطره عليها في مدينه
نعم منطقه ام درمان منطقه الاذاعه هي ظلت
محل مناوشات واشتباكات متبادله ما بين
الطرفين اليوم اعلن المناطق باسم القوات
المسلحه في تصريح انه تم تحرير هذه هذه
المنطقه ولكن
ظهر فيديو يبين ان قوه الدعم السريع مع
تزال موجوده بحسب ما ذكره اعلامها الرسمي
يتجدد القصف في هذه الاسماء يتجدد ذوي
الاسلحه الثقيله بشكل مكثف بعض
الشيء لو كنت تستمع اليه
صوت غير واضح بشكل دقيق ولكن اي الجهات
التي يسمع او تسمع منها هذه الاصوات واذا
كان الوضع فيهم ام درمان بهذه الطريقه
ماذا عن بقيه مدن الولايه العاصمه الخرطوم
وايضا الخرطوم بحري بما يتعلق بخروقات
الهدنه
نعم اليوم كما اسلست منطقه شرق النيل شهدت
اشتباكات وكذلك طلعات جويه استمرت منذ فجر
اليوم وكانت متواصله حتى قبل قليل
اشتباكات بشكل متقطع في عده مناطق في
العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم بمدنها
الثلاثه
ان اشير كذلك الى ان كانت بالامس هناك
حاله هدوء نسبي كانت هناك وضوء ملحوظ
مكانا المواطنين من الخروج عكر صفقه هذه
الامس هجوم مجموعات متفلته على الاسواق
على السوق الشعبي في
جنوب غربي مدينه ام درمان وكذلك سوق
برمانا الكبير الذي تعرضت اجزاء منه
لعمليات النهب بمجموعات متفلته تستقل
عبر الاشعه البيضاء هي تستقل ظروف
الامنيه وحاله السيوله وتمارس عمليات
النهب تروع المواطنين بحتى كبير
من مكتبه عربيه في السودان شكرا جزيلا لك
وبعدها كانت نواه الحراك الشعبيه الذي
اطاح بنظام الرئيس السابق عمر البشير
تحولت مدينه عطبره الى قبله او قبله
الهاربين من هول الصراع الدائر بين الجيش
وقوه الدعم السريع
[موسيقى]
عمليه اجراء الرعايه رعايه دول الاجنبيه
من شرق السودان صوب ميناء جدا وعبر مطار
دخلت يومها العاشر اكثر من 16 الف طالب
اجلاء غادروا البلاد من خلال شرق السودان
خلال الايام الماضيه غير ان الاافا بين
السوريين واليمنيين ومقيمين سودانيين في
عدد من الدول العربيه يواجهون صعوبات في
سبيل مغادرتهم للبلاد العربيه ترصد الواقع
من شرق السودان
عشره ايام مضت على اول عمليه اجلاء لرعايه
دول الاجنبيه من شرق السودان نحو مختلف
الدول العالم عبر ميناء بورسودان وعبر
مرها الدولي اكثر من 20 رحله بحريه تمت
حتى الان ونحو 45 رحله جويه من مطار
بورسودان الدولي تستمر عمليات الاجلاء دون
توقف غير ان اوضاع الرعايه السوريين
المطالبين بجلائهم تشكل استثناء هنا عم
نطلب نروح جده
نروح جده وبعدين نروح نحن اي بلد
فيزا اربيل عراق مصر اي اي مكان ما حدا
سال علينا العيال في الشوارع النساء
الشباب مضى معه مصاري هاي ما تصرف الحمد
لله الشعب السوداني ما هو مقصر ابدا لا من
اكل لا من ملبس لا من ماء
طيب لايمت هذا الوضع ازمه الاخرى تشهدها
المنافذ نحو الخارج حيث يواجه السودانيون
المقيمون في عدد من الدول ظروفا صعبه يقول
كثير منهم ان اوضاعهم لا تحتمل تاخر
اجراءات مغادرتهم للسودان نحن عندنا
اقامات عندنا زيارات يعني في ناس خلصت
طيب نحاول الحكومه واقفه والبلد واقفه دي
مشكله برضو
فبالناشد كل السلطات يا جماعه انه لو في
امكانيه توفر لنا بواخر نحن بحقنا بتذاكر
بنشتري كل السودانيين
مستطيعين انهم يدفعوا حق التذاكر بس ما
موجود بواخر نحن كسودانيين مقيمين في
السعوديه
نناشد السلطات السودانيه والسلطات
السعوديه انه يسرعوا في اجراءات اجلانا من
مدينه بورسودان الى المملكه العربيه
السعوديه لانه عندنا طلبه عندهم جامعات
وعندهم اسر
الشفقانين علوم شديد ولازم يصلون باسرع
وقت
للمواجهات المسلحه ارتدادات مختلفه يامل
كثيرون هنا ان لا تتمدد لتشمل قطاعات اخرى
نزار البغداوي لقناتي العربيه والحدث
مدينه بورسودان الشرقيه السودان
مع الزميل نزار بقداوي نزار كيف تسير
عمليات الاجلاء من بورسودا حتى الان
محمد العمليات الان تمضي هذه العمليات
بدات منذ الحادي والعشرين من شهر ابريل
الذي مضى عبر ميناء بورسودان وبدات يوم
الثالث والعشرين من الشهر المنصرم عبر
مطار بورسودان الدولي العمليات مستمره حتى
هذه اللحظه التي نتحدث فيها البواخر
والقطعه البحريه
والسفن الحربيه تصل تباعا الى ميناء
بورسودان للاستمرار في عمليات الاجلاء عدد
من رعايه الدول الاجنبيه والعربيه
والاسيويه وصلوا بالفعل الى ميناء
بورسودان ووصلوا ايضا الى مطار بورسودان
في اطار استكمال الاجراءات لمغادرتهم من
البلاد اكثر من
23 رحله بحريه تمت خلال الايام الماضيه
نحو اكثر من 35 ايضا رحله جويه تمت خلال
الايام الماضيه عبر مطار بورسودان وهذه
الرحل في استمرار وفي ازدياد المعضله
الحقيقيه محمد التي تظهر خلال الايام
الماضيه وظهرت اليوم وخلال الساعات
المقبله نتوقع ان تتفاقم هي استمرار وجود
الاف من السوريين واليمنيين ما زالوا هنا
في مدينه بورسودان لم توفق اوضاعهم بعد لم
يستلموا تاشيرات المغادره من مطار او
ميناء بورسودان حالهم يغني عن السؤال كما
يقول كثير منهم يطالبون السلطات السوريه
والسلطات السودانيه وحتى السعوديه بضروره
الاسراع في توفيق اوضاعهم بغيه خروجهم
وخروج النساء والشباب وكبار السن من
الوضعيه التي يعيش هنا في مدينه بورسودان
طيب كان هناك اشتراط واضح من السلطات
السعوديه يتعلق بوجود بلد يستقبل هؤلاء
واقصد بلدانهم فيما يتعلق بحل مشاكل
التاشيرات واللجوء وما الى ذلك ولكن نزار
عندما نتحدث عن عمليات الاجلاء هل نتحدث
عن جميع المدن السعوديه السودانيه بما في
ذلك المدن الاكثر استقرارا عن الخرطوم
وبورسودان
وخرطوم او
الخرطوم بحري او حتى امدرمان مثلا
هذه المساله تحتاج الى توضيحات وهي
كالتالي كثير من السودانيين فضلوا البقاء
على الرغم من ظروف الحرب والمواجهات
والاشتباكات كثير منهم فضلوا ان يظلوا في
منازلهم حتى مع اشتداد وطاه الاشتباكات
والمواجهات اظلوا فيهم درمان في الخرطوم
في مدينه الخرطوم بحري في شرق النيل هذه
هي النقاط هذه النقاط الملتهبه اما في
دارفور في الجنينه في الفاشر في مدينه
نيالا في زالنجي ايضا عديد من الاسر فضلت
ان تظل في مناطقها ولكن المناطق الملتهبه
اثر كثير من المواطنين ان يغادروا غربا
باتجاه دوله تشاد على الحدود الشرقيه مع
دوله تشاد اما البقيه من السودانيين فقد
اضطرتهم الظروف الحديث هنا عن من يمتلكون
اقامات في عدد من الدول العربيه على سبيل
المثال في الامارات في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه في دوله قطر هؤلاء اضطررتم
الظروف الان وصلوا بالالاف الى مدينه
بورسودان في سبيل الخروج ولكن ايضا هنالك
صعوبات تواجه ما يريد ان يغادر السودان
لكن كل المنافذ كل المدن التي تتمركز فيها
عمليه خروج السودانيين وغير السودانيين هي
مدينه بورسودان في شرق السودان المعبر
الحدودي بين مصر والسودان في منطقه اربيل
على حدود السودان مع مصر في ولايه القضارف
في منطقه الجلابات على اتجاه السودان
ومنطقه المتمه على الحدود مع دوله اثيوبيا
هذه هي المناطق وهذه هي المنافذ الرسميه
والرئيسيه التي يخرج منها السودانيون
ويخرج منها غير السودانيين في طريقهم الى
مغادره السودان نتيجه للاوضاع المتازمه
التي شهدتها البلاد خلال الاسبوعين
الماضيين
شكرا جزيلا لك
عشرون الف لاجئ سوداني يعانون مراره
اللجوء في تشاد اغلبيتهم من النساء
والاطفال ومنهم من يعاني من امراض خطيره
خيران اليونسيف حضرت من البقاء في تشاد
خوفا من موسم الامطار المقبل
خطا نهايتها عصيه طريق اللجوء يطول وصلنا
وحيدات الى تشاد لاجئه سودانيه دون مواعيد
بعضهن تمكنا من الدفع فقل عليهن عبء
الطريق نساء واطفال هربوا من حرب اشتعلت
فجاه خيار اللجوء لا مفر منه ضمن حرب
بحصيله كبيره للقتله
البيوت وقد قتلوا ثلاثه نفر اربعه كده
عشان كده
استقروا هنا على الحدود الارشاديه
السودانيه كبرات السن لم تعد لهن القدره
على المضي بينما الاطفال اغلبهم يعانون من
امراض تنفسيه وسوء تغذيه
20 الف لاجئ سوداني استقروا في قريه
كوفرون تشاديه قريه تفتقر لاساسيات الحياه
وضروره تغيير المكان باتت حتميه
اذا فشلنا في التحرك الان سيفوت الاوامر
سياتي موسم الامطار قريبا واذا لم نقدم
مساعده للناس سيتم اغلاق الطريق وسيظل
اللاجئون عالقين هنا
يبدو ان البقاء هنا طويل مخيم اللجوء باتت
تتشكل ملامحه عشرات الاسقف واعمده علها
تشد بيت لاجئ الى حين عوده غيداء السالم
العربيه
وعلى عكس عمليات نزوح واللجوء والاجلاء
استطلعت العربيه راى سودانيين على الحدود
المصريه السودانيه قرروا العوده الى
بلادهم رغم استمرار الحرب يقولوا الوضع
بقى احسن شويه واحنا شايفين في قنوات
حسن ويعني ما فيش مشاكل دلوقتي يعني ما
فيش حاجه يعني فعشان كده اضطرينا ان نرجع
بلدنا يعني انا مش خايفه انا اللي عليا مش
خايفه
راح اخاف وهي مشكله انا بعتبرها لانها هي
دي
مشكله ما بينا
شخصين
مع سمرار المعارك في العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم تزداد الاوضاع البعشيه سوءا يوما
بعد يوم هذه قصه عائله اضطرت الى ترك
منزلها بعد انقطاع الماء والكهرباء والعيش
على وجبه طعام واحده في اليوم
من نافذه غرفه صغيره تراقب هبه شوارع
مدينه غاب عنها الامن والسلام منذ اسابيع
خرجت مع عائلتها الصغيره من منزلهم في
الخرطوم بعد انقطاع الماء والكهرباء جراء
القتال
لتستاجر العائله غرفه فوق سطح مبنى في
منطقه اخرى من العاصمه لعلها تجد فيها بعض
الامان وابسط اساسيات الحياه
لكن صوت ضربات مدفعيه والطيران والرصاص
كان مصاحبا لهم كيف لا وهذا هو الحال في
الخرطوم كلها منذ اندلاع الصراع اصوات انا
كل يوم بسمعها
مدعبه شديد يعني بخاف على ناس البيت بخاف
على نفسي
بتمتمات ودعوات تصلي والده هبه من اجل
ابنائها ومن اجل وطن غادره الامن
والاستقرار وعمت فيه الفوضى ولا يعرف ما
ينتظره ان شاء الله ربنا يعني يدي العافيه
والناس تبقى كلها طيبه الوضع يرجع لوضع
الطبيعي ونرجع بيوتنا لانه طولنا بالجزم
من بيوت الكهرباء قاطعه
الدعامه قاعدين قدام بيتنا
نصلح العمود بتاع الكهرباء طبعا الكهرباء
ما في مويه ما في عشان كذا انا زحمه فرقنا
البيوت
قلقوا العائله الصغيره وخوفها ليس من وابل
القذائف والرصاص فحسب بل تخشى ايضا من
انقطاع الامدادات الغذائيه فلجات الى حياه
الكفاف ما في مواد غذائيه
كل الدكاكين مقفوله والموجوده باسعار
غاليه شديد بنحاول ناكل اكل قدره حد
الكفاف يعني بناكل وجبه عشان تكفينا باقي
المواد الموجوده لليوم اللي بعدي لانه ما
معروف قصه من بين الاف القصص لاسر تكافح
في الخرطوم وتبحث عن ابسط حقوقها حق العيش
في سلم وسكينه وسلام وربنا يصلح الحال
ويرجع حال السودان احسن من اول بكثير ملوك
الشيخ العربيه
سيد خالد اهلا وسهلا بك الى هذه التغطيه
ربما بعد ايام من التفاؤل باستقرار الهدن
التي تشهدها السودان عاده
الاشتباكاتره ربما اعلى من الايام الماضيه
ما الذي استجد ودفع الطرفين الى تصعيد في
هذه المرحله
تحيه لمشاهدكم الكرام ابتداء والرحمه
والمغفره لكل شهداء الوطن
بالتاكيد الذي دفع الى يعني
افشال الهدن هو محاوله يعني استفاده من
هذه الهدى لتعزيز المواقع العسكريه وجلب
مزيد القوات من قوات الدعم السريع
لا يمكن ان تستمر الهدن في ظل محاولات
الاستخدام اساليب وتكتيك لتحسين المواقف
التفاوضيه او تعزيز المواقع العسكريه
لتحقيق المكاسب العسكريه على ارض الواقع
وبالتالي في تقدير الشخصي انه انا الاوان
لكي تكون هذه الهدن هدن جاده وهدى تلتزم
بما يعلن الغاده من الطرفين بانهم راغبين
راغبون فعلا في الوصول الى اتفاق يعني
ينائى بالدم السوداني من هذا الاقتتال
اخر على استمرار كل الهدنه السابقه قد
تكون بوطيره اهدى ولكن الخروقات مستمره هل
هناك قوه دوليه او محليه او اقليميه قادره
على اجبار الطفر طرفين بشكل جدي وقف اطلاق
النار والج على طاوله المفاوضات هذه المره
انا في تقدير الشخصي
انه الهم الوطني والشعور بمعاناه الانسان
السوداني والخسائر الفادحه التي ارتكبت في
حق الشعب السوداني المغلوب على امره
والتدمير للبنى التحتيه هذه ان لم توقف
الذين يعني يدفعون باتجاه اختراقات الهدن
لن توقفهم اراده دوليه او تسليط عصا
المجتمع الدولي المطلوب هو ان يتعقل الناس
ويبدو تفكير حقيقي في بالنظر الى ما ترتبت
عليه الاحوال خلال الاسبوعين الماضيين
وبحساب الخساره والربح انا في تقدير
النقوات الدعم السريع يجب ان تعيد النظر
في استراتيجيه المواجهه لانها خسرت خسرت
اغلب قوات العسكريه خسرت كل المعدات
العسكريه او اغلب المعدات العسكريه واصبحت
معزوله تعمل من جزر معزوله في جيوب في
الخرطوم وهذا يدفع الى مزيد من الخسران
الواقع ان العمليه المباغه والانتشار
الكثيف لقوات الدعم السريع في الساعات
الاولى من هذا الهجوم قياسا بما هو عليه
الحاله الان خير سبب لكي يدفع قاده هذه
القوات لكي يتقدموا خطوه نحو الامر
ويعلنوا هدنه جاده توظيف هذا الدم ويقبلوا
بقضيه الدمج ولينوا بهؤلاء الشباب الذين
يجيبون في معركه خاسره امام الجيش
السوداني الذي هو يعني يمتلك قدرات كبيره
ولم يهزم على مر التاريخ وبالتالي هذه
معركه خاسره في المحصله النهائيه يصبح من
الضروري تحكيم صوت العقل والنظر الى ما
تحقق من مكاسب ان وجدت اي مكاسب هي لا
توجد مكاسب والنظر الى الخسائر الفادحه
التي هي تحدث عن نفسها الان في الواقع
العسكريه على رغم من التفاؤل الاممي كما
يتحدث المبعوث الامميه للسودان
هناك موقف واضح من الرئيس الكيني الذي قال
بان الطرفين تحدث عن الطرفين هنا رفضا
بشكل قاطع وقف اطلاق النار على الرغم من
دعوات المجتمع الدولي والايجاد والاتحاد
الافريقي هل هناك حتى تضارب في المجتمع
الدولي فيما يتعلق بالموقف من الطرفين من
هذه الهدن
وبالتاكيد الموقف الدولي يستند في الاساس
على التراكم الطويل للتدخلات الدوليه
السافره للحد البعيد في الشان الوطني
وهناك حاله اصطفاف افصعد عنها اربع سنوات
ونصف من الممارسه السياسيه المختله التي
فتحت الابواب على مصراعيها لتدخلات دوليه
لم يصبغ لها مثيل في السودان وهذا الواقع
انعكس على المشهد الحالي معظم القوه
الدوليه تتعامل على استحياء وخجل كبير في
التعاطي مع الملف السوداني لان لديها
تراكم طويل من الانحياز اللي فيها قليله
يرفض الشعب السوداني ويرفض الثوار وترفض
القوه الحيه في المجتمع هذه القوه الدوليه
بلا استثناء تدخلت بطريقه لم تكن يعني
تخدم الهم الوطني السوداني بصوره خالصه
وهذا ما جعل حائط صد بينه وبين الدخول في
عمليه تفاوض جاده ولكن هذا لا يمنع وجود
بعض الدول في الاقليم وبعض المنظمات
الاقليميه من شانها ان تؤثر بحكم ارتباطات
التاريخيه للسودان مع هذه المنظمات على
راس هذه المنظمات دول الايجاد والاتحاد
الافريقي على راس هذه الدول المملكه
العربيه السعوديه وجمهوريه مصر وجنوب
السودان هذه الدول الثلاث بالاضافه الى
المنظمتين الدوليه الافريقيتين يمكن
العباءه دورا مهما ولكن وبصريع العباره
البعثه الامميه لا تستطيع ان تحقق اي
اختراق لان هي التي كانت راس الرمح في
الاختراق المخل باستفاضه مع قوه مدنيه
حزبيه صغيره واراد فولكر بريدس ان يفرض
سلطانه وجبراته
وصلاحيات هو ليس مخول ليناقشه يتحدث عن
الدستور يتحدث عن قضايا هو ليس ليست من
تكليفه هو جالي دعم الانتقال ولكن مجموعات
من القوه المدنيه التي هي تمثل مقلب قط في
المؤامره الدوليه يا شعب السوداني استطاعت
ان تعتلف وان تنكس رؤوسها لكي تمر انتاج
اكثر من مره وهناك ايضا لكل المكونات سواء
كمكون مدري ولا مكون عسكري هذه المرحله
التي نتحدث عنها مرحله تحقيق المكاسب على
الارض من اجل تعزيز المواقف التفاوضيه الى
متى
دعني اكون اكثر صراحه معك بالنسبه لبعض
الناس المعركه التي تجري رحائها في
الخرطوم تدور رحل الان في الخرطوم وفي بعض
المدن السودانيه هناك من ينظر لها انها
معركه السياسيه لكن انا استطيع ان اؤكد لك
ان الشعب السوداني في غالبه 99% من الشعب
السوداني اربعين مليون ينظرون الى هذه
المعركه بانها معركه حياه او موت معركه
ليس دون الا النصر لانه اذا غدر للشعب
السوداني ان يهزم في هذه المعركه فعلى
الدنيا السلام ستضيع الدوله وستطيع موارد
الشعب السوداني ولذلك افضل للطرف الاخر ان
يقدم تنازلات للجيش السوداني لا يقاتل
واحد هنا اربعين مليون رجل وامراه يقاتلون
من خلف هذا الجيش وعلى اهبه الاستعداد
لحمل السلاح لكتابه نصر الشعب السوداني في
هذه المعركه ولن تتوقف هذه المعركه الا
بانتصار الامه السودانيه
ماذا نريد اكثر من التدخلات الدوليه من
الذي سلح من الذي وفر التمويل من الذي فتح
الاجواء من الذي يريد ان يدخل اجانب لغ ضد
الشعب السوداني من عاصمته هذه ليست بهذه
اتهامات هناك شواهد حيه كنا نظن قوات
الدعم السريع في غالبها او كلها ابناء
الوطن السودان ولكن شاهدنا مشاهد مؤلمه
وهي التي اثارت الحنقه الشعبي وهي التي
وحدت الوجدان الوطني السوداني الذي لديه
حساسيه مفرطه مع المستعمرين ايا كان
مصادرهم يعني ليس هناك سقف للخسائر لا
نهاب الخسائر المهم اننا ننتصر هذا هو وطن
السودان لا يمكن ان نسمع لاي اجنبي هل
يدخل مع قوات ويختلف مع ابناء وطنا لكي
يحارب شعبنا في الخرطوم هذا الكلام نحكي
لك انا من هذا الاستوديو هذا احساس جمعي
متوحد حول الامه السودانيه متوحده حول
القوات المسلحه هذه المعركه معركه كرامه
معركه عزه معركه تحرير الوطني من الاجندات
الوطنيه فلن يكون مسموحا بعد هذه المعركه
لتدخلات دوليه ولن يكون مسموحا بعد هذه
المعركه لا يخترق في الوسط السوداني
والايام ستشهد بذلك هذه معركه لانغاز
السودان وشعب السودان من كارثه حقيقيه كان
يمكن ان تمرر ويصبح السودان اسير لاجندات
دوليه وسلطانه
ولكن الاهم في هذه المرحله هو وجود غودنا
حقيقيه لانقاذ ما يمكن انقاذه وتقديم
المساعده والدعم للمدنيين المحاصرين في
منازلهم في الخرطوم من لندن خالد العايصر
الصحفي سوداني شكرا جزيلا لك
السودانيون يواجهون خطر المواجهات
العسكريه بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريعه
الدائره منذ ثلاثه اسابيع وعلى الرغم من
الاوضاع الامنيه المترديه يضطر الكثير
منهم الى التوجه الى اعمالهم ووظائفهم
المختلفه لاعاده اسرهم في ظل اوضاع
اقتصاديه وانسانيه صعبه
لازم اشتغل يعني في الظروف
يعني اي حاجه زايده لازم انا اشتغل يعني
زي ساعتين ثلاثه وقفل لانه البلد ما امنه
ما في يعني اي حاجه
احنا تقريبا حوالي 3000 4000 5000 العدد
كبير جوا البناء وبرهوا على الكورنيش
الناس تكون في الارض ارامل اطفال مسنين
مرضى احنا قاعدين في الارض ويعني اغلب
الناس قاعدين في الاراضي كلنا جايين اماكن
بعيده اغلبنا اتيه من الخرطوم
في مشهد موثر لعمليه اجلاء نقل افراد من
البحريه السعوديه شابا من ذوي الاعاقه من
ميناء بورسودان الى سطح سفينه الدرعيه
المتجهه الى جده
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
العربيه الثالث
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات